thank you for joining us at noon i'm
john langler we are still following
breaking news from the south part of the
las vegas valley two people dead after a
plane
fell from the sky and crashed near
valley view and pebble road there you
see the
neighborhood where this happened we have
team coverage joe mohler is live at the
scene as well as kate houston we're
going to start with kate houston with
the latest developments from clark
county fire department
kate
yes well here where i'm standing there
are still multiple fire engines
and police cars here assessing the scene
i'm going to step out of the way so you
can get a live look
now where you're looking right now is a
construction area
fire crews tell us the plane crashed
right next to that trailer
into a cinderblock wall on your screen
there should be footage
of a plane in flames directly after it
crashed
this happened around 9 40 a.m after it
took off from north las vegas airport
ccfd says it was a twin engine cessna
310
that can hold five people now only two
were on board at the time
now that fire did spread to the nearby
trailer where a man was
actually inside at the time bruce
langston is building a home on this
property
he says he heard a loud noise saw fuel
spill
and a ball of fire
it looked like a movie scene from the
worst horror movie you've seen
so there was nothing i could do i ran
back to my office i grabbed my computer
and
started becoming overcome by fumes left
i dialed 911 several times but within
seconds i heard
a police siren so i knew someone had
been alerted
witnesses described seeing the plane fly
very low for hundreds of yards before
crashing
at this time we do not have any
information on who was on board
the faa does believe that they were
headed from north las vegas
to an airport in san diego now at this
time the faa will be taking over this
investigation and we are waiting for
more information of them but we're going
to go live
to joe mohler who is near raven and
henson street with reaction from
witnesses joe
yeah kate we spoke to a number of people
in this area about what they saw but
i'll give you another perspective of
this you said
we're at raven and henson i'll give you
a pretty close look we're about 100
yards away from where this crash
happened you can see
investigators and crime scene
individuals are over there
working this investigation one man we
just spoke with was working in this area
and he says he actually saw this plane
really low
coming straight down raven here in this
area coming from
going eastbound from west and they said
he said that he believes he was trying
to land here on raven he said that he
saw that
man actually opened the door and looked
out the window he noticed the propeller
was
not working properly when he was flying
over is really low
almost hit a home here he said than when
he came out to see what happened he
noticed
that this plane had actually hit the
ground here and he ran over to see if he
could help but by that time
it was already in flames now let's go
and take a look at these photos of this
plume of smoke that people saw in this
area for
quite some time after this all happened
people from blocks away were driving
over here just to see
what exactly happened trying to figure
out what it was we did speak to a woman
named barbara mora she lives
a couple blocks away from where this
crash happened she tells us her husband
had called her at around 9 47 to see if
she was okay
and she went outside and saw that plume
9 47 my husband called me
and asked if i was ok because there was
a plume of smoke
in our area and i walked out and sure
enough there was one
so i got in my car and drove over here
and
saw some smaller flames
but saw mostly the smoke
a lot of people are saying the same
thing when you're when it comes to that
plume of smoke many people curious about
what happened people still driving out
here to
to get some answers of this what exactly
happened now back out here live you're
taking a look down raven you're looking
westbound there this is the street that
that man who is working in an empty lot
here
doing some dirt removal said he noticed
this plane just slowly flying over he
thought he was going to land here
on raven but by the time he got out here
to the street to see what happened that
plane had
already crashed here right outside of
that trailer like kate was mentioning
but obviously this investigation is
continuing as soon as we learn more
we'll be sure to pass it on
reporting live joe moeller 8 news now
all right joe thank you very much we've
gotten a lot of responses from you the
viewer from this plane crash we'll have
those coming up as well plus